this is dave klein reading for chris
pereira diablo 2 is back with diablo 2
resurrected while the remaster isn't all
that different from the original game
with its primary differences being a
visual overhaul and quality of life
improvements it still does contain some
mechanics that can be worth discussing
for new players and even veteran diablo
3 players so here are some essential
tips for diablo 2 newcomers
your first decision upon booting up the
game is choosing the right class
unfortunately like many games of this
nature without having played any of the
game it can be hard to choose which
class is right for you while diablo 2
does let you roll additional new
characters there's still no swapping
classes once you've made your choice so
anytime you sink into a character will
be for naught if you decide you'd rather
play something else while this is an
entirely subjective choice some classes
are definitely better suited for
newcomers than others paladins and
necromancers are our choices for good
starter classes paladins can take plenty
of damage and can heal without potions
meanwhile necromancers can summon an
army of minions who will not only dish
out damage but more importantly distract
and absorb enemy attacks helping to keep
you alive
and look there's no issue with choosing
a class that you think you'll have more
fun with they just might be more
difficult like the sorceress who's
heavily dependent on spell casting and
mana
but is relatively frail making it a more
challenging character to play solo at
the start
[Music]
there are numerous class builds and
radically different ways of playing as
any given class
so a good strategy is to min max your
character's builds and hone in on
improving the abilities that best serve
the way you play and the strategy you
intend to use while you're free to mix
and match skills as you wish it's
generally best to make a plan and invest
accordingly you have a limited number of
skill points to a lot meaning you won't
be able to acquire everything in the
skill tree and even if you do invest
heavily in a particular skill that may
dictate what other skills you should
choose due to skill synergies
resurrected features a respect system so
you aren't entirely locked into the
choices you make but there are
limitations on it so don't plan on being
able to freely experiment at the same
degree that you can in diablo 3.
one gameplay mechanic that might catch
you off guard is stamina essentially you
can only sprint for a limited period of
time before running out of stamina and
being forced to walk you can toggle
between running and walking on your own
to preserve stamina and ensure you
aren't left on empty if you suddenly
need to put some distance between you
and an enemy while some items like
stamina potions can help provide a boost
is still something you should always
keep an eye on along with your health
and mana particularly if you're playing
solo
the first time you die you might be
surprised to find that you'll respawn
back in town
sans gear in order to recover your loot
you'll need to make your way back to
your corpse and pick it up
but
without any armor you'll be extremely
vulnerable so keeping backup items in
your stash for these cases is a smart
move though be aware that you'll need a
room in your inventory to pick up your
previous items if you're venturing into
a tough fight it's also wise to open a
town portal before starting which will
save you the frustrating walk all the
way back to where you died
luckily if you do die again before
recovering your corpse you'll just drop
additional corpses so this isn't a case
where you only have a single chance to
get your gear back you can also save
yourself some potential headache by
storing gold in your stash ensuring you
won't need to recover your corpse to get
it back of course if you're playing on
hardcore mode where single death spells
to end all of your progress is lost upon
death but at least you won't need to
store pesky backup armor right
be mindful of fights with enemies who
can resurrect their allies and when you
can always tackle them first they're not
just respawning hordes of enemies on
repeat definitely pay attention to the
enemy attributes displayed at the top of
the screen where you might see a stat
raises fallen showing that this will be
an enemy who can use resurrection
throughout the game you'll encounter
other enemies that should be prioritized
ahead of lesser foes
among the items available from the npc
acara your first quest giver are two
tomes one for scrolls of town portal and
another for scrolls of identify these
scrolls are highly useful as the former
let you quickly visit town and then
return to the action while the latter
reveal hidden attributes on items which
must be done before they're equipped
you'll always want to have some of these
scrolls on you even though they do take
up some inventory space
that said each of these can hold up to
20 of their respective scrolls so they
are definitely worth the space
investment once you enlist the help of
deckard kane the need for scrolls have
identified will be dramatically reduced
and he'll be able to identify items and
mass whenever you return to town but
you'll want access to town portals
throughout the game
you'll come across a lot of loot as you
play and not all of it is necessarily
worth picking up while you can sell
anything back in town repeatedly
returning can quickly become tedious and
will cost you a small amount in the form
of a scroll of town portal
as such your time is better spent only
picking up more valuable items those
that are specific to a class like wands
sacred globes scepters barbarian helmets
and so on are a good bet as are rings
amulets and items that provide a point
to one of a class's skills
focus on nabbing these instead of bolts
or other low value items that take up a
lot of space to maximize your earnings
and reduce the number of trips back to
town you need to make
diablo 2 doesn't have an end game like
you'd expect from a modern game and
eventually you'll likely spend a lot of
time on boss runs where you repeatedly
square off against the boss to earn
better items
but even before reaching that point you
may find yourself underpowered so you'll
want to grind out xp and items by
repeating certain sections of the game
tristam the countess act 1's catacombs
act 2's tombs act 3's council and so on
are fertile ground for earning xp more
quickly than usual so be prepared to
make your way through these numerous
times
everyone can enlist help even without
diving into multiplayer as you progress
through the early act 1 story you'll
gain the ability to hire your first
mercenary from kasia you can only have
one merc at a time so you want to make
sure you choose one that complements
your class
pay attention to their skills when
looking to hire one a rogue with cold
arrow might be less useful to you if
you're a sorceress who can already slow
down enemies or a necromancer with
summons who will divert enemies
attention once you have a mercenary make
sure to equip them with gear to increase
their effectiveness also of note is that
ethereal items which can't be repaired
are useful with mercs due to the fact
that merc equipped items don't lose
durability
[Music]
early on you'll begin acquiring gems
that can be placed into items with
sockets these can be extremely
beneficial and socketed weapons in
particular can provide you with a major
damage boost even if the inherent
attributes of an item aren't great bear
in mind that a sufficient number of
sockets can be transformative if you use
them in the right way
and that's where room words come in like
the various gems you'll find runes can
be placed into sockets for beneficial
effects but if specific runes are
inserted into items in a particular
order you'll activate a rune word which
provides extremely important effects
that go beyond what the individual runes
would normally provide this allows you
to even be able to use abilities for
classes that wouldn't normally have them
you can find rumored lists online from
the original game but a crucial thing to
note is that they're only compatible
with items that have gray text
for example magical items which are
designated by their blue text don't
support rune words all of that said the
stats of the item are still relevant for
making the most of a room word so don't
be too quick to throw runes into the
first item with sockets that you happen
upon in the early game farming countess
in act 1 is a good way to acquire runes
in act 2 you'll acquire the haradric
cube by placing specific items inside
the cube can convert them into something
else there are tons of recipes but it's
important to know that even something as
simple as chip gems can be placed inside
to upgrade them to the next level of
rarity three chipped rubies become one
flawed ruby while three flawed rubies
become one ruby and so on three runes of
the same type can also be combined to
obtain a different specific rune or an
equippable item can be upgraded to the
next rarity level
[Music]
so these are all of our beginner tips
for you if you're new to diablo 2. and
if this is your first time playing get
ready for one of gaming's classics and a
game that would go on to be hugely
influential in the industry if you
enjoyed this video make sure to hit that
like and subscribe button and let us
know what you think of diablo 2
resurrected
oh
okay